Star Trek Discovery is dead there will
be nothing Beyond season five but what
does that mean for Star Trek and what's
next for Star Trek welcome to side track
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so on this channel we have discussed a
few times now that Paramount plan to
quietly remove Alex kurtzman from Star
Trek we discussed that actually the
current contract that Alex kirchman has
ends in April but there is an extension
but the contract he had up until then
was specifically states that he will
produce Star Trek for Paramount the
extension doesn't have that distinction
it doesn't mention Star Trek it that it
would just produce stuff for Paramount
so from April he could be quietly
removed from the Trek franchise and that
that wouldn't upset a lot of trekkies we
would actually probably quite like Alex
kurtzman to really be removed because
under his watch we've seen a lot of
let's say dodgy Star Trek now the other
rumor was that actually Paramount hoped
to roll Star Trek back and ignore some
of the mistakes under the kurtzmann era
and bring us a Star Trek that we
recognize more from like Deep Space Nine
Voyager the Next Generation era now I
would actually argue that they've
quietly already done that if you
actually look at what we've seen so far
of Picard season 3 The Star Trek
universe it's based in looks way more
like the Next Generation than it looks
like discovery
so does that mean we are finally out of
the kurtzman era and that the future of
Star Trek is Rosie well maybe not
because Paramount just before the
announcement of the end of Star Trek
Discovery also announced that they are
going to be decreasing their streaming
budget quite dramatically they like a
lot of other streaming services owe a
lot of money and the next thing having a
lot of pressure put on them by the stock
exchange Etc by the people who actually
control the money to start making a
profit none of the streaming services
except maybe Netflix actually make any
money at all and there's been an
understanding for a long time that they
needed to spend money to make money that
streamer services at the end of the day
are a new thing but that period has come
to an end they will no longer be their
massive amount to spending with no
return I mean Disney Plus for example
has been losing 500 million dollars a
quarter that is not sustainable even for
a company the size and their might of
Disney
so 2023 might actually be the peak of
streaming spending and we might see a
lot less in future so what does that
mean for Star Trek well one thing it
means is probably less serious at the
moment we've got five Trek series on the
Run Picard lower decks Prodigy Discovery
no more and strange new worlds I could
see that that's probably going to shrink
down to four I'm very much doubt we're
gonna have five series but hey
if they announced something I think
it'll be at the end of Picard but what
is the rumor now the rumors have been
for quite a long time now the Alex
kurdsman wants to do Starfleet Academy
did Starfleet Academy would be based
around the discovery time period and
would be a spin-off now that kind of
makes sense Starfleet is on his knees
where we see it in Discovery and by the
end of the series Starfleet is on a
Resurgence the Federation is back so
they would need a new Academy and that's
what the series would be based around
I don't want to see that crap I don't
want to see Star Trek 90210 please guard
somebody get rid of kurdsman immediately
if that if he generally thinks that's a
good idea because again the rumor is
they want to appeal to a younger
audience
just
no
if you want to do a good show do a
spin-off with the Titan with seven of
nine as Captain or sure as Captain
except I think he probably dies in The
Next Episode or two but you know maybe
he just goes yeah I'm dead but no no I'm
not doing it and just comes back to life
that would be awesome sure zace I want a
grumpy captain and Starfleet that'd be
great but a seven of nine captain of the
of the Titan going out there monster of
the week type show look at the end of
the day strange new worlds works because
it's got brilliant characters and it's
got a different story each week I would
actually argue that the stories aren't
that great if you actually break down
the show
it's not great but the characters and
the because it made so well and it's
made with a bit of fun way outweighs any
problems the show has any any lack of
creativity in some of the you know some
of the stores unfortunately but it's
it's a brilliant show because the
characters are brilliant Discovery You
could argue he's got better stories but
it's got no characters so that's why
it's failed
I would actually argue that the best
Star Trek at the moment and the Star
Trek that we should be looking at to
give us an idea where Star Trek's going
is actually a two animated series lower
decks love it or hate it is based around
the Next Generation time frame it's very
familiar if you're a Next Generation fan
and it's been popular because of that
Prodigy as well is very much based
around the Next Generation time frame it
feels like Deep Space Nine that type of
show the style of it the look of it
everything else so for me I think that
is a strong indicator of what they're
going to do in the future but whatever
show they decide to do I think we are
going to see two things I think they
will sell a license and they will revert
back to the previous business model of
letting other companies
share some of the cost of the Star Trek
shows so there's a deal with Amazon to
help produce Picard but that deal was
um sort of re-jigged so that it would
appear on Paramount plus first
there was a deal with Discovery and
Netflix that worldwide Discovery
appeared on Netflix but again that deal
was rejig so that it would appear on
Powerman plus first actually was the
last season even on Netflix I don't
think it was because I've not seen it so
no it wasn't even on Netflix so that
deal again was reject but that means
they've lost that money from Netflix
um obviously the two animated series one
has a deal with um Prime worldwide and
um obviously Nickelodeon share the cost
of Prodigy but Nickelodeon's owned by
the same company
so that's not really sort of sharing the
wealth if that makes sense it's just
taking the money from a different part
of the business but
I actually genuinely believe we'll see a
revert back to that type of um deal
where whatever new Star Trek is produced
will be produced in cooperation with
either Prime Nickelodeon Apple I know
they're desperate for some big sci-fi
project so that's a possibility
um Paramount will look to get extra
income by basically licensing out Star
Trek now I've heard rumors that they
would look to sell Star Trek no chance
the big companies like this and they
never sell their IP they might license
it out for a period but they never sell
their biggest eyepiece so they're not
going to sell Star Trek to anybody
but as I think they might loan it out
I also think that whatever's TV series
we then do get to see he will be far
more like Star Trek the Next Generation
D Space Nine and a voyager in look and
feel then early Discovery
um we're not going to see weird freaking
Klingons we're not going to see that
Dark Universe maybe as much I think a
lot of the stuff with the romulans in
the first series of Picard that'll just
be forgotten about
um I think we're going to see far more
that even though these things might be
referenced very occasionally think about
the second episode of Picard season
three when
um the biggest mistake in Picard season
one Turner Picard into an Android was
very subtly referenced by Captain vatic
she just said ah Jean-Luc Picard in your
synthetic skin and but that was it
um
and I think that's the way Star Trek
will be in the future they might
reference their mistakes very subtly but
they will move on from them
so is the future bright for Star Trek
it really depends what we get to see it
really depends if kurtzman I already
think his name is being moved to the
periphery again if you look at season
three of Picard Terry mattalis has
really took the lead and even though
kurtzman's name is still on there I
don't think his fingerprints are very
much on this series but let's see what
happens because Discovery being canceled
is a big indicator it's a big indicator
that lots of these rumors that we've
been hearing might be true and that in
fact Paramount is in far more financial
trouble than maybe they'd like to admit
and that the Paramount plus experiment
maybe hasn't gone as well as they'd
hoped and they're gonna have to roll
back a lot of the spending a lot of the
bet that they put up the Paramount plus
would be the success and they're going
to have to take the hit on it
so
Star Trek the future and what's next
we'll have to see but the next couple of
months are going to be very interesting
and if we don't get an announcement
after Picard season three of a new Star
Trek show
then I'd be very worried that actually
the future of Star Trek might be far
more limited than what we've been
enjoying in the last couple of years but
guys get in the comments tell me exactly
what you think what is your opinion
about the future of Star Trek I'd love
to know
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out to
us so you'll miss none of our new videos
also you can go over to patreon
Sidetrack and join us there for a small
fee you'll get most of our videos before
everybody else on YouTube and you don't
have to watch the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign